and here come the hornets in the
attacking zone where zeus gonna go all
the way
blocked by jones lead for lebron and the
king is there to slam it
defense to offense for two damian jones
with the rejection and
lebron with the finish mellow lamella
the bounce and it's stolen by schroeder
turnover by ball taken by lebron here he
comes in the spin cycle to score
lebron james oh great speed phil
he did a great job of getting back but
didn't get in that good position there's
another look
at him with the spin move gets the hoop
and goes to the floor but
they had numbers advantage he gets up he
runs down the floor and then
i know i was just checking him out over
there and i'm thinking has he touched
the leather yet here is lamello all the
way up the one-point lead despite
the last hoop alamello
he's closing in on those as well as he's
the league leader
this year triple-double stewie tonight i
know you're watching a lot of that
that's lebron yes sir from three
zeller listen bill this carl's cam look
at this shot by lebron
fading into the corner out of bounds and
when he's when he finally goes through
he's defense that time
by biambo he didn't get the whistle at
the other end played by
matthews as he ties up lamelo takes it
away
thc lebron with the finish
he strips on the way up comes away with
the clean steel
that leads to the lakers getting an easy
deuce and then the very next possession
coming down
he does another great defensive play and
lakers again it's wesley matthews his
third steal
leading out of kuzma to lebron the
trailer
look out below i love the way the lakers
get out and run
good defense turn them over getting out
and running and when you run you end up
with some
good looks
sit from the outside quickly they kick
it out of the net kuzma blocked by pj at
the other end
secondary defender no name did he block
he completely controlled it
ball once again trying to get to the rim
spins it up and in
now he does not have one
all of a sudden it's a 10-point game
again lebron making 13
with lebron hitting the triple got it
james going into the dribble with one at
the buzzer lebron
perfect what a way to end the half for
braun the king and the lakers
so the lakers have five to shoot
schroeder knows it misses
damian jones was there lebron stays with
it and pulls it up and in
and how did he come away with that one
charlotte fifth in the east just four
games separate four through ten
in the east rozier got it
before the lakers need a timeout do they
ever
hornets are really on fire to start this
third quarter so the lakers take the
time out and
they need it a week week and a half yeah
but the 25th deadline so yeah there's
going to be a lot of action
enrolling is lebron and finding him as
markeif
now the interest level has uh perked for
the charlotte hornets as we mentioned
the buzz is definitely back for them
ball from distance he's got it lamelo
ball drains the three last possession
down he knocked down the three-pointer
lamellar ball or carlsbad with a great
view of him
drilling his first triples five minutes
of this third quarter makers have
four points so far in the third quarter
and lamela
ball goes all the way to tie the game at
64.
timeout lakers just like that the
hornets are
tied with the lakers after trailing in
the first half by as many
as 18. real nice delivery nice rotation
on the ball
lakers from three-point country tonight
seven for 25 and lamelo answers back
what they call
why didn't i get a whistle it's tied for
seventh in the nba
and made threes and it's gonna be five
on four
tht slow getting up ball is open on its
way the rainbow is good
for lamelo ball lamello knocks down one
on the other side and we have a
one-point game
now the king back to the basket 8 53
remaining in the game
lakers lead 9185 fall back for two
dennis the menace all the way to the rim
there's that change of pace
and lamelo scores he answers right back
ball
where's the defense right now great job
when he turns his body like that because
defensively it's hard to get to it
he's been running that play since he was
a kid
[Applause]
and foul lanello attacks gets fouled and
keeps his focus on the target
three-point opportunity
caruso with eight to shoot gonna give it
to lebron
oh caruso the cut the score with lebron
finding him what vision what vision
hornets another
at lebron finding caruso as he cuts to
the better they come it's one on
four so graham did the smart thing
but the quickness now rolls here blocked
by james
as he came over to block it from rozier
they beat me with the first step but you
better be able to finish
up here i come and there he goes
still in it here though lakers hanging
tough
that most of the way schroeder lost it
lebron's got it
boy schroeder re-gathered in mid-air
didn't it ball they've got to do
whatever
they're going to do quickly and lamelo
backing in gets doubled up
in trouble stops turns around and scores
kept his pivot foot
an off first half that's one thing
players realize there's 48 minutes in
the game
just because you don't do well the first
half doesn't mean anything and lebron
he lays it in for the last lakers shot
at the game
two more he's got 37 tonight